so Russell C Davies has revealed that
one of the reasons he chose to return to
helm Doctor Who was that he was aware of
the increased budget and resources owing
largely to the participation of Disney
now that's interesting and also makes a
fair amount of sense one would imagine
that the ability to do stuff that was
beyond the scope of the resources he had
originally would be part of the reason
to come back so that it would be less of
a repeat because he was working with
bigger resources and could do more
things it also would account for some of
his Ambitions since he has already said
that they are already working on
spin-offs I will have a more detailed
video down the line with my thoughts on
that it is too much for a short but I
have to say that overall that's not a
bad reason to come in some might try and
twist it as oh he's just doing it for
the money but he's talking about the
money to do more I hope that it doesn't
turn into a case of just trying for more
effects and make it prettier but rather
an increase in scope and ambition of
narrative
but we'll see